here we are run over time Chris we
didn't get to talk about your book on
the show it's a great book thank you I
so here's a question about it what
contributes to the racial disparity and
policing in this country that's a nice
when you buy the [ __ ] book exactly
that's it that's the topic of the book
you might want to summarize it and I
need one thing I would say I hope people
read it the when we tend to focus on
police misconduct or police shootings
and one of the points of the book is
that that is a small fraction of an
inordinate amount of amount of
interactions right and in the past 20 or
30 years particularly we have changed
the goal of policing from essentially
solving crimes to sort of preserving
order right the whole broken windows
revolution that happens starts starting
in the 1980s is that police job is to
prevent crime from ever happening right
as opposed to solving crimes when they
do happen and what that means is an
unbelievable amount of police citizen
interactions in particularly
neighborhoods of color and poor
neighborhoods and a huge amount of those
end up in the sorts of situations we see
recorded on videotape at the same time
that that's been happening we've seen
homicide clearance rates in this country
decline even as homicides have gone down
so we have gotten out of whack in what
we think of policing should be doing and
it's sort of at the core I think of
where we found all interesting max do
you expect Trump to make good on his
promise to take better care of our
nation's military veterans as the author
of World War Z we want to know that I
expect him to throw an incredible amount
of money at it as he does everything
will that money be managed well or will
it go into new weapons procurements that
we don't need probably the latter right
I don't expect him to take care of
anybody except him right
Louise will Britton come to regret
brexit no no it was an eye if your eyes
be on war breakfast I am massively for
breakfast and what is that today I'm for
breakfast I am for breakfast doesn't
that make you a Putin wacky and knowing
us I was like it happy possible to have
a Venn diagram what I do right mama pono
I work with Muslims for Britain who was
some of the biggest supporters of
breakfast because before breakfast white
Europeans you know somebody from Belgium
was privileged had the right to come and
live in Britain whereas people that were
are citizens who have got relatives in
Pakistan hat couldn't bring them over
because Europeans got priority so it's
not miles raj and donald trump and you
know maybe putin likes dogs I like dogs
you know there could possibly be an
overlap maybe I am for accent I'm not
British he doesn't like dogs or
Europeans but no one's all bad I
understand brexit I do I mean I
understand why somebody in Britain would
go you know what Greece is always in
trouble and then meaning bailing why is
that my problem it's always to say
somebody asked me this is it always the
same countries that need the Bala is
like yeah kind of
you know Spain Portugal Italy the sunny
places where people are [ __ ] from
wonderful rhythm yeah it was first their
GDP is lower they're sleeping and
[ __ ] in the day I mean it's a
reasonable trade-off so it really was
only policy the money I mean just it's
portrayed it's really racist but if the
President of the United States in this
case it might be good seeing given who
is President had to go to the Prime
Minister of Canada for permission every
time we wanted to do something and also
get the president Mexico to sign off as
well and he couldn't do as anything yes
oh I have to get it permission to do
laws then we just basically felt we
should be able to govern ourselves you
know we're big boys and girls and if you
would like to join into the United
States of Europe thank god bless but
once you realize the game no no I just
feel like there are dirt reasonable
sovereignty issues that go to questions
of brexit and also question of some of
these free trade agreements where the
end of the day America should be able to
do what America what's in America's
interest and they don't define over
their sovereignty to other entities and
that school is a matter
our mirror 300 million of our well
together late in the end if one
criticism clearly is a cornerstone of
conservatism when you pretreat becomes
bad for conservatives I'm a conservative
all right I don't think it is tell you
what I think in bed when Trump won the
election right Yeah right that's
suddenly they did a big 180 on that
because it's all about winning
I think sending with Russia you know
it's like it's okay as long as they help
us win right that's not to me is what I
get from their view about Russia
I think the brexit question was this
basic question of should the UK be able
to determine who comes into their
country you know if you come into one
part of the EU doesn't mean you should
be able to go anywhere you want I think
there are basic rules and regulations
that a country should set and I think
when it comes to these trade agreements
actually don't think these trade
agreements are very free I just think
their contracts okay protection if they
they they discriminated against poor
third-world Caribbean sugar producers
for example at the expense of rich
friend reform intrude and that's not
preached way that's protection but she
brings up a good point about Muslims
because there was a large section of
England that did not want Muslim
refugees coming in via Europe the cruel
joke on those bigots is that those jobs
still need to be filled and they're
gonna get filled by Commonwealth
Government Reform round and muslin
candle congratulations no more but
oldest Catholic they're putting in a bid
this guy you know what a Secret Service
guy who's is a terrorist this guy you
did the terrorist attack you look at he
can read he's from Birmingham which is
which is heavily Muslim and and some of
the schools there were actually teaching
his form of Sharia law this is a fact
I'm not making this up
there are also been many acid thrown in
the face attacks okay Mike let me ask
this I've asked this question before if
a European country sometime in the
future became 51% Muslim would it be the
same country had the same values the
same laws with laws change it's not that
question about Jews big I will what do I
question about Catholics I will ask that
question and the answer is it wouldn't
change because they were already the
[ __ ] majority but not Muslims are not
if you telling me that if a European
country became 51% Muslim it would
basically be the same country you grew
up in the program would not bring Islam
it will be heard
and we homogeneity that you're the
homogenous but it all right every single
everybody is one favorite we're on our
fundamental principles like equality of
women separation of religion and state
respect for minorities rule of law right
opposed to religious rule do you know
about Westboro Baptist Church there are
a whole bunch of fundamental a missile
so docile and singer Matt please yeah
I'm going to hurt your right agent over
you boys anything about know what that
is look god we have to call things as
they are and I hear a lot of moderate
Muslims below armies in a fight
absolutely idea God with them that you
can have it you can have a civilization
where you have religious pluralism they
themselves those Muslims don't believe
in that religious oh man well you tell
me that's we those history can you
explain to me the structure of the
government of Indonesia I can't okay
do you know that Indonesia is the
largest Muslim country in the world I
read that I do yeah yeah yo and right
but then so do you tell me you don't
know anything about the way that the
largest Muslim country in the world are
arriving I think it is excited in Asia I
could tell you that in Indonesia if you
want to be a woman policeman or a woman
a military person you have to undergo
the two-finger test where they tell if
you're a virgin
what does that contagious problem it's
not Britain without what I want you say
that we're not completely crazy that
assimilation in addition we might
argument we can't connect some of the
bar got sick I got to go take care of my
cold
thank you very much everybody
[Applause]